اطلقت نقابه اطباء السودان نداء عاجلا
للمنظمات الانسانيه والهيئات الصحيه
الدوليه والاقليميه لتقديم العون وتوفير
الامداد الطبي لجميع المستشفيات والمرافق
الصحيه بالخرطوم ومناطق الاشتباكات
بالولايات المختلفه كما طالبتها بضروره
الضغط الالزامي طرفي الصراع بوقف الاقتتال
وتوفير ممرات امنه للمدنيين وسيارات
الاسعاف والكوادر الطبيه ودعت النقابه
جميع الكوادر الطبيه للمؤازره نظرا لوجود
اعداد كبيره من المصابين والحالات الحرجه
التي تحتاج تدخلا جراحيا عاجلا
وكان الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع
قد اعلن الاتفاق على فتح مسارات مؤقته
امنه للحالات الانسانيه وفقا لبيان للجيش
فقد تمت الموافقه على مقترح اممي بفتح
مسارات امنه للحالات الانسانيه اعتبارا من
الرابعه من عصر امس الاحد ولساعات معدوده
مع الاحتفاظ بحق الرد على قوات الدعم
السريع من جهتها اعلنت قوات الدعم السريع
موافقتها على هذا المقترح مشيره في الوقت
نفسه الى حقها في الرد على ما سمتها
ميليشيات النظام البائد